this is us this is you this is you on
May 20th yes what it is I say blood
hashtag happiness that's what I see I
like that hashtag so yeah I would say I
haven't been this happy to start a new
job since I sold lemonade at the end of
my driveway it's a bright morning to
come it is really indeed and Gail I've
sat in here hundreds of times in this
green room and you come in and you talk
to the guests and so I'm gonna throw the
question that you always throw to all of
our guests that appear on CBS's what's
that what is the one thing that you want
everyone to know about what will happen
come may 20 I want people to know that
we are resetting the table that it's a
brand new day the bones of this show I
think are very much intact
and I think that now you know we're
starting with a with a new team but I am
really psyched about it the good news is
two viewers nobody here is a stranger
right that's that's do you think that's
good that's absolutely true to your
words who are watching you I can say
who's that guy yeah I mean at least
everybody that's sitting here you have
seen us before yeah and now you'll see
the three of us together and I just
think that that's a very cool thing
now we also work together before I know
each other well yeah we respect each
other we really like each other and
hopefully they'll see that too
yeah and I think the news is about
conversation and you know to the best
conversationalist in the business and
you're not so bad yourself
[Laughter]
Anthony you have really done practically
every job here at CBS News in your 30
years you got served you coffee even
have on this show is we won't be able to
have a cocktail Saturday I was think
about this because I've been doing a
show for Sep almost seven years down
which I got fed and I got a copy that is
a very big sacrifice I'd tried to
convince people here to bring the
cocktail to the show but it's not
happening I'm happy but I'm you know I'm
still am extremely excited yeah how do
you like croissants and bagels we're
very
I actually come in after your so
sometimes they kill them Ellen we got
that that's good yeah eating in that
sense is a little better yeah for sure
um Tony you are prolific writer you
wrote an incredible book about your dad
called the last pirate yeah yeah our son
in the golden age of marijuana an
unlikely the lineage for a network
anchor I think my father is a fell into
class 1 drug dealer and he made a lot of
people happy dealing marijuana I think
we can make people happy do that
information yes your new dad
I am indeed well yeah jus Latian see you
and Katie thank you very much but he has
two other son so you're not new to the
dad I am NOT new to the daddy first time
I did it I was in my 20s and now I'm in
my 30s and you know there's a big I
think he took the job because he knew
he's already gonna be up like it's not
gonna be hard for you to get up this
early in the morning what's with the
socks let's just get that okay so the
the socks my mice one says tipsy fuddled
boozy and groggy is that how you feel
and in fact I have no explanation for
what is on the socks other than the
following my wife loves the band Phish
they are apparently a ping people follow
them and she has dozens and dozens of
pairs of fish themed socks which she
shared with you that's she doesn't share
them I take them and and this is one of
them is um buddy will have to interpret
this for me because I have no idea you I
don't know his wife is Kate eaters you
know competition how's that gonna work
Tony there she's a nemesis for well
she'll brief me for all political
coverage I think that'll be a beneficial
that's taken care of and you know we'll
debate things heartily around the dinner
table
yeah yeah I'll be right you're in good
company because there are a couple of
senior producers at CBS this morning
Peter Burgess Brian bigging I'm there
there are those guys who follow fish
around like well so your office I'll
take the stocks from my wife and they
can take them from my office all right I
have some like rapid-fire questions that
I want to go with you guys so the first
one I thought of and of course I thought
of this first question with all of you
in mind but specifically you Anthony
with the first one if you could be on a
desert island if you are on a desert
island and you could only take with
you one book one movie in one record
what would it be the one but the movies
easy it's Chinatown Chinatown the book I
have to think about the record is tough
because I could mean I could take a
thousand I wouldn't have another one it
would probably be it would probably be
dusty Springs Dusty Springfield record
or Memphis recommend like yes yeah yeah
see from dusty and Memphis yes dusty in
Memphis what about you yeah no no that's
good that's the only wreck you could
only take one record I would taken an
anthology of some kind okay so you
compilation yeah so you could get a lot
like the Motown anthology so you would
get a lot of different artists okay I
like that idea
I still love Sleepless in Seattle it's
not my favorite movie but I do love that
movie
yes that never gets old to me book in a
book Michelle Obama's be coming with the
benefit of going third and I will go
with a Phish album now and as a former
that has a former high school basketball
player I'll go with white men can't jump
as Woody Harrelson Wesley Snipes a book
Mystery Train buy a grill Marcus great
book origins of American rock and roll
that is a great book and what do I need
now yeah even now you know even though
I'm a young man this is that I guess an
homage to my father it would be early
Jimmy Buffett maybe a margarita one food
you can't live without peanuts and
peanut butter peanuts and peanut butter
yeah yeah I will I will spend sometimes
when I'm at the checkout counter with
peanut butter the the the cashier will
warn me that it's $12 no but I'm aware
of the price just give me the peanut
butter I will I will pay any amount I
will I am a peanut tourist I've even
gone too far you know it's right or no I
am like I am a hey if you had Reese's
chocolate peanut butter I have I have
you don't like it we if something in my
tone suggested yeah the way you went I
have it with chocolate no I don't like
it I I like you know you know what is
the very but this is a tip for any
insect the therapy no I like Skippy Jeff
a a sub-brand of jiff
from peanut farmers themselves they will
tell you that Smuckers
is the best peanut butter that's a
sub-brand of real quick as we're getting
a wrap Gail your food 1/4 cup cake
without cupcakes cupcakes bourbon
exactly this dynamic is incredible like
either way that you guys are playing off
of each other I mean that's what we're
gonna see what works liked and you can't
you can't plan chemistry either you have
it you don't but we're off to a good
start because as Toni's as Anthony said
should I change my name to use for both
of us you is good to him just said you
know we're starting out where we like
each other respect each other admire
each other and I think that's a really
good start
yeah well we are excited congratulations
to everybody this is going to be an
amazing year Dinah Miller is here - our
executive producer he's a 20th Lady
Diana callers CBS this morning